i don't think i've ever invested in a
business that didn't have technical
co-founders
very quickly from the beginning
sometimes they'll go and they'll build
like proof of concepts or they'll build
early early iterations to basically
validate the value that they're bringing
into the market almost immediately
thereafter you have to go find the
people who are going to build the
technology in-house who are on your team
because you internalize
that
that
cycle in terms of the ability to make
changes and evolve and adapt and you
internalize that knowledge whereby when
that sits external to your team like
you're gonna run into a world of pain
when the time comes
this would be like running a bakery
and then you're ordering your pastries
from a factory and then bringing them to
your bakery and then putting them out
there and you dress as a baker yeah
that's what a person who doesn't build
the technology in-house is basically
doing
and
eventually imagine you're investing and
you're like oh wow tell me how you made
the croissant and they're like i go to
this website and i order how many
croissants and they bring them and then
i put them in our box and then i sell
them i want to invest in a baker
at a bakery you're a storefront
that buys from another bakery so what is
your skill exactly
there have been examples calendly is one
where they were able to build it the
founder sunk hundreds of thousands of
dollars from his corporate sales job
into it from what i understand so it can
happen for your mvp maybe but i think
with no code now
and all these great
platforms bubble and type form and if
this then that and zapier and notion
slack airtable all this stuff asana
they're all working together you can
build a no code solution and maybe get
there on no code too so keep that in
mind okay jake via email what is the
most attractive intangible qualities of
a founder
is it grit tunnel vision empathy
flexibility clarity of thought etc
i like to say i love founders
that are dumb enough to bash their head
through brick walls but who are smart
enough to realize sometimes you can walk
around it yeah great so you like to have
that
like they'll never give up they'll be
dogged
but they're also savvy and they're
willing to think outside the box and try
other strategies
you know at the end of the day many
different intangible qualities can make
a successful founder i've met introverts
extroverts i've met
engineering folks and i've met artistic
folks you can have a designer like
airbnb
you could have a dogged travis with uber
who is just a great leader of people and
a visionary you could have larry and
sergey who are engineers you could have
elon who's an engineer
you know there's a lot of different
prototypes here and
the the truth is having a product that
you want to see manifest itself in the
world and you are relentless in the
pursuit of that and building a great
team if you can build a great product
and build a great team
it tends to work out so i think
who can build a great product who can
build a great team somebody who is good
at building product and somebody who's
good at
getting people to join so if you can't
find your co-founder if you can't find
your first employee you may have failed
the first test which is you're just not
able to recruit a team and if you can't
build a great product well back to that
baker analogy with the previous question
it's kind of like
well who are you what qualifies you as a
founder you don't have the ability to
build product you don't have the ability
to recruit teams i've always been really
good at recruiting people
and building enthusiasm and conceiving
of products and marketing them and
branding them that's been my skill set
i've always been able to find technical
people to work with me so no big deal
but some people are not good at the
recruiting thing
and they're not good at product and i'm
like what are you good at and they're
like
i don't know maybe i need to work on
that
there seems to be like
the the thing i find problematic about
this question jake is
what are you gonna do change your
personality like
to fit what i what zach and i said here
at the end of the day build a great
product build a great team delight
customers and have them not shut up
about your product those are things you
can actually change in the world you're
not going to be able to change your
empathy flexibility clarity of thought
like these are hard things for you to
change in our personality
just make a great product build a great
team delight customers
and you got a really good chance of
getting funded okay matt via email from
your career as an entrepreneur investor
what are the similarities between all
successful startups you're seeing again
back to pattern recognition i hate these
questions because they really
show a lack of knowledge of the space
which is many different things can
succeed
and the similarities there are
similarities but
many different things succeed i don't
know do you can you think of
similarities or do you get annoyed by
these questions like i do
yeah there are both i think everything
in this business is there's a yin and
again in that each side of the coin is
true so on one hand all great businesses
are new there's some new idea that
hasn't been done before there's some
insight there's some aspect that is
amazing but the other side of it is like
some great businesses are just like take
an existing business that's not new at
all and just do a way better job of it
like we've seen that over and over
they just make it they just go in and
they realize how stupid it is that this
existing business does something in this
dumb way and they're like okay we're
just gonna fix it and do it right and
and they're just the same but way better
so
and i think in every aspect of this
business the yin and the yang is is a
truism is that all things are true but
in their own particular ways around
startups yeah but yeah i agree with you
there's no there's nothing that's
consistent it's they're always different
well it's yeah there's many different
ways to get to the destination many
different ways to win
the things that don't change is building
great product building great teams
and delighting customers as far as i can
tell those three things do not change
i've never seen an outlier business that
did not delight their customers had a
terrible team and they didn't know how
to make a good product is there an
example of a team with a bad product
that
a succeeded team there's tons of teams
that like build really crappy products
that have become very successful what's
the most successful crappy product i
don't know webex like god but but at the
time i think it was the best of the
worst so it's only bad in relation to
how good zoom and
some of the new products are i think
yeah but there's i think there's a lot
of products i don't want to like start
pointing fingers and naming names but
there's there's a lot of products out
there that i have to use on a daily
basis and they're terrible and the
businesses are amazing that's the
opportunity then for somebody to make a
better one yeah somebody's going to
exactly
well actually if you think about it
think about how bad friends are in
myspace were before you use facebook
facebook actually made it stable
right now linkedin is gonna give you a
hundred dollar credit towards your first
ad campaign i'm telling you the call to
action upfront so good linkedin.com
this week in startups to get that
hundred dollar credit towards your first
air campaign if you want to get a group
of people who are receptive and who are
doing business they're doing business on
linkedin right when you market on
linkedin your message reaches people who
are ready to engage with your business
this means your ad campaign will work as
hard as it can as soon as you launch it
need more evidence to use linkedin
marketing over 78
of b2b marketers rate linkedin has the
most effective social media platform for
reaching objectives because there are
over 62 million decision makers on
linkedin you know that and they mean
business linkedin equals business equals
linkedin it's that simple folks and
here's how linkedin marketing stands out
they have the tools for brand building
or lead generation you can pick you can
target professionals down to their job
title company name and location and you
can engage folks you already know based
on previous site visits or outreach so
you can do that retargeting thing do
business where business is done get a
hyundy get 100 ad credit right now go to
linkedin.com this week in startups once
again for a hundy linkedin.com this week
in startups no spaces no dashes
linkedin.com
this week in startups terms and
conditions apply because they're giving
you a hundy